yeah but when you what was um I don't
know if you're okay I'm just gonna ask
this if you're okay what was that one
was the first time that you have I
guessed
wait did you did you date any boys you
know this yeah I did
I had boyfriends in high school I do it
but I can't remember and then in college
it was so that was my moment of
discovery of trying to like penis who is
good-looking
looks like like a baby's arm holding an
apple what is this is that it looks like
it looks like a baby holding a little
baby Apple looks like cats with veins on
it a very muscular babies on Oh so when
you so when you were going through those
experiences it was just more like you
know you don't feel like an emotional
connection you don't feel I never felt
you know this is really weird and I've
never actually talked to anyone about
this but I there's a difference between
connecting with for me with a woman
versus a man in what sense with a guy
sometime and I don't know where this
comes from and maybe it's because I'm a
neatly born gay but for me as a when I
meet with a man it's I feel a level of
having a wall up and if they violate
that space in any way it it scares me
mm-hmm and there's something there's
like a trigger in my body that's like
you're not safe you don't like this
isn't for me it's really it's bizarre I
can't really explain it but I have a lot
of really close friendships with males
but I don't ever think about anything
further that's because you're gay this
is because you're gay no I understand
what I'm trying to tell you like this
this alarm system that goes off
but when I win it when a man comes up to
me as a heterosexual male
he gets an inch away from my face on
alarm system goes off - it goes what are
you doing so you get it then okay so
going back to my childhood so I was
brought up and my dad who I respect very
much he has always brought his children
not to be well he has two daughters so
women of agency so he's always said you
know what do you want to be when you
grow up you can be anything you want and
he's always encouraged us and he's never
put us down on any ideas that we might
have about our futures and I think
because of that were really headstrong
but we're also really sure of who we are
and what we want to be and I think that
directly contradicts to what my parents
want from us now but now I'm like well
it's a little it's a little late you
know you were having us order our own
food at restaurants at age four five wow
that's amazing
right dope which is great because you
feel this kind of independence and now
when I date someone who tries to order
for me I'm like this is never gonna work
because I don't see as chivalrous I see
it as someone who's trying to take my
autonomy away from me damn dude you got
some deep-seated issues homie when I'm
at a restaurant or somebody I'm gonna
order for him light then you also go and
pay [ __ ] cuz if I don't like this not
able to [ __ ] hope you take that
responsibility too you just got thrown
right back in their face they go you
know what I got this that's how cool you
also got the bill - then the [ __ ] or to
me this [ __ ] that I want oh god but
but now I think it's kind of coming back
to them in a really negative way because
they're unable well I I wouldn't say
they're unable to respect us I think
that right now it's a lot of confusion I
came out to my parent my mom last
February she's actually my first family
member
outside of my cousin's that I came out
to
so when I came out to my mom I had a
level of I mean I was terrified the
whole drive over to my house I was
sobbing like just sobbing because
essentially my mom had called me a week
before and she said who is this woman
who is this woman that you're always
hanging out with and running to whenever
she calls and you're like going on trips
together like what's happening I just
get this really weird feeling and at the
time I was in Virginia and my I remember
I was in the car I was in the passenger
seat and my heart just dropped and I
knew this is the conversation that I've
been waiting to have with my mom for a
really long time like the better part of
a decade right and I'm like I can't
believe it's come down to a feeling like
a maternal feeling that she's had and
she's asking me these questions
frantically over the phone and I just
said my heart's racing and I just
remember saying okay I'm back in
California tomorrow let me go home and
then I'll come visit you
well sure and she said okay well please
yes please please please call me back
call me tomorrow before your flight
please units like I just I need you to
do this and I was like okay I'll just
call you later I couldn't call her that
whole day and the next morning I wake up
my hands are sweating I've packed
everything to go I can't stop crying and
I'm just feeling like this moment of
reckoning right it's like she's gonna
disown me I'm not gonna have any family
members anymore and for me that's a huge
blow because my mom's like my best
friend and so I go back to LA I'm crying
and at the time too I had just come out
of a relationship so I was in the midst
of a breakup and oh yeah yeah there's a
whole story oh yeah we don't want to go
they don't want to go then we don't have
time for that blue no plus I'm still mad
at you for that so I go home you know I
was living with Susan yeah
and Lydia and Ellen came over to my
place I think I think they come over
like every night
for I went home and I was like crying
telling them you know I have no family
anymore I don't know how I'm gonna tell
my mom and I remember it was I think
Susan or Ellen said something like you
know give your parents a chance give
them a chance to surprise you because if
you walk in there defeated you're you
know like there's no positive outcome to
this yeah it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy
right and I just thought okay maybe I
can tell my mom I don't think I'm
prepared to tell the rest of my family
so I'm so anyway cut back to me crying
in the car like praying praying for an
hour saying please help me like I don't
know what to do I feel completely
hopeless and lost in this situation
because essentially I've like lived my
life very freely and the way I wanted
for a decade and now I'm having to go
home and explain myself and this is
someone that I've known for 31 years and
now I'm telling her you actually don't
know me whatsoever because here's this
massive thing that I've been hiding and
I remember that night that the girls
came over my mom had sent me a cacao oh
yeah
look I was like this Korean messenger
thing for people who don't know and she
said in Korean she goes Eunice my heart
every time I think about you my heart is
broken open and tears streamed down my
face because I love you so much
something like that like really
traumatic of course yeah and but of
course at the time too I'm like oh my
god I don't want to be breaking my
mother's heart like that broke me and
then that would cause more to end then
essentially when you cry so much your
eyes are so used to crying you can't
stop crying and then it anyway it's this
horrible vicious cycle so I'm home my
dad greets me at the door he's just like
hi yeah Eunice is home and then I'm like
hi dad and heart's like just and then my
mom is like I'm cooking in the kitchen
so I'm like okay this seems this seems
fine like this is Noor
we go into the kitchen my mom's like
okay food's almost done she's completely
avoiding eye contact with me I'm so
nervous I don't know how to behave in
that moment and my dad's just rambling
on and on he's like asking me about my
work and asking me about my life and
that kind of calms me down because now
we're talking about something that
doesn't have anything to do with then
I'm like well maybe dad doesn't know yet
so this is good and then we're eating
and my dad and I are really getting on
and then my mom is silent and my dad
looks at her and he goes hey why are you
so quiet why aren't you saying anything
and she looks up and she goes Eunice and
I have a few things that we need to talk
about before like God before I can join
in on this conversation heart drops food
plops out of my mouth it was like oh my
god I my dad immediately goes okay great
see you later runs out of the kitchen
he's scared of stairs right all yours so
why do we have 17 locks on the door he
runs upstairs I'm like okay clearly he
knows something right but he's not
willing to be a part of this
conversation right now which is better
for me because I was so uncomfortable
and so my mom starts talking and the
first thing she says to me is you know
Eunice I've been doing a lot of research
and the first thing that I wanted to
tell you and I think this comes from a
nervousness too and I when I realized
that and I clocked that it's not just me
who's nervous she's equally as nervous
no she's like I've read on like Korean
like Naver which is like Google um that
homosexuality is harder to get out of
than drugs and and I was like that's so
funny
and I was like okay mom can I just
please please stop you right there she's
like yeah okay and she like shuts up and
she's staring at me and she's so much
like fear behind her eyes and I said
look mom because she wanted you just to
say I'm not gay right and I said you're
I said look I've known that there was
something different about me since I was
six years old and the whole Drive
from LA to my parents house I told
myself don't cry when you're coming out
to your parents because when you cry it
takes away from the severity and the
realness and the authenticity of what
you're feeling
you really think yeah I don't I mean I
was always brought up to be like don't
cry don't cry don't cry but also I think
though there's a vulnerability in crying
but there's also a moment where when
you're telling someone something that
means that that means something real and
I don't know there's something about
that moment where I felt like I need to
tell you in a way that you understand
and I'm gonna be very logical and
explanatory about this and I'm gonna be
patient and sit here and listen but the
last thing I wanted to do was be like a
puddle right and so I'm telling her I
knew since I was six years old and all
of a sudden I'm I without any prompt I'm
like sobbing you know like full sobbing
like I can't breathe my mom gets up I'm
like holy [ __ ] she's gonna hit me or
she's gonna be like she's gonna drag me
out but I'm so I'm just so upset with
myself for crying and I'm also just so I
don't know I was just uh I was so wreck
yeah my mom reaches over me and I'm like
bracing myself she grabs these napkins
and she's standing over me and she
starts wiping my face hmm and she and I
can feel her tears just oh my gosh now
I'm gonna cry but I can feel her tears
like hitting the top of my head which in
turn makes me sob harder because I never
want my mom to cry because of me I never
want her to feel anything but pure joy
and happiness when she thinks of me
right and she starts wiping my face and
she's like I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
that you've had to like live with this
for so long by yourself and and then
she's like and then she's and then she
kind of and I felt like oh my god she
she gets it or she's sympathizing and
then she says and I'm so sorry it's my
fault
and I think that's when the tears kind
of stopped cuz I said it's not your
fault
and I really need you to understand that
it's not your fault it's no one's fault
it's just though it's just what it is
and then we kind of digressed and then
she started to ask me more pointed
questions about my sexuality in the
coming days and I thought well there
really is like light at the end of this
tunnel and then it just went south but
that was more recent well she doesn't
get it so for she isn't she's not
accepting of it I think I think Koreans
do this thing where they try and justify
anything negative with an explanation
right hmm so it's like